they would killing killing it's no use
one lies no use and you're killing
people over it the wonders what did I do
to die postcodes drugs because all these
people won't lie you look up to their
misery if there's one thing that brought
me is because I was taught a lifestyle
oh when you have money and power and
girls and this start this is happiness
so one day I was with one guy a rich guy
my money's crying he's on alcohol is on
drugs and I'm thinking fine I want to be
like you I'm struggling and striving to
be like you and you're here crying
what's going on it didn't add up to me
yet you know why because Allah tells us
only with the remembrance of allah your
hearts find peace
do you know what that means my brother
that means there's laws and legislations
are last put in place there is gravity
here when you drop something it falls
that's a legislation that we can see
happen there's also glory that we cannot
see what that means is Allah has put a
condition you will never find peace by
accepting what that means profit the
money that you're gonna get you're gonna
get bored the ghosts are you gonna have
you're gonna get bored the house you can
have you gonna get bored you want bigger
you want bigger I had friends who were
going training the gym they get big with
Missy next my walking that's bigger they
get depressed you know why because they
all want to be like him and problem when
you're gonna be lucky we're gonna find
somebody else that's bigger than him
you're looking for something I like yeah
you go to that girl go out there you
know a non-believer nothing else my
heart once I know it's the car that's
see I need to work for the car how do I
get the car I can't do a 95 this guy's
not gonna get me it even though there's
prophecy or mashallah who have done it
you have businesses who have done it if
you want so what you do you start
another thing your heart is yearning for
Allah your hacia Allah Allah Allah
you're giving it money cars drunk one
lie is not going to have to profit your
happiness you're never gonna find her
personal life you see some believers
they have nothing nothing you see a rich
multimedia I want the guys I don't know
what makes this guy happy I just want to
be happy like him
one day to make it yes these flashy
fiends all these photos of stuff one of
you guys it's up to you brother
and I'll finish with this a Bedouin man
came to the prophet peace be upon him I
said what must I do
be a Muslim why is my requirements
what is all not one for me something
massive no it's a pretty fast time today
he said okay let's Allah I would pray
five times just five times a day no
problem he said give me the traffic that
I'll give 2.5 sin a penny more not a
penny less I'm fasting Ramadan I'll go
ahead if I have the means to as the man
walked away the Prophet SAW Allah made
you since that's it when I first came to
struggle with budget but brother you
know very well if I came to you and said
at 4:00 a.m. in the money I'm gonna call
you who and I want you to do is get up
brother and be for 10 minutes and I'm
gonna give you two hundred pounds I'm
never gonna see millions if you get you
want I wanna give you fifty pounds the
fifty pounds just to get up for ten
minutes I swear to god you don't even
sleep you say I'm never gonna see if I'm
I don't miss that just in case I will
not wake up
but when Allah is promising you Jenna
it's okay that's too much for me that I
can't was one lighting something please
fix oh I'm and I'm not seeing that you
guys are not just a general man to
everyone because these people are gonna
be watching this let me Allah bless you
guys may Allah grant every single one of
you guys Jenna I'm here look um as you
guys know I get a lot of messages I'm
here today if there's anything that I
hope can help remove a key buffer I'm
here come ask me questions if there's
anything that I can do to help you
please may Allah bless you guys for
listening me Allah grunts every single
one of you guys Jenna but Alcala fees
ha ha yeah
you know I told you
I'm in a sauna 30min urgent nothing warm
up